yeah welcome to this video playing a
renegade from Canada let's see grune
felt no Kings Indian Oh f3 f3 okay let's
prepare the same ish Ross Bishop e3 it's
not that's not a big difference yeah the
only 97 this is actually um very
nowadays a very rare way to play because
you allow night a 2 3 night age three sm
the way white wants to develop night age
32 f 2 on f2 the night has a very good
good post it covers those crucial
squares like g4 and the pawn on e4 so I
really want a nylon f2 and this helps me
quite often white even goes tonight e to
g 3 h 1 f 2 ok so what is this I mean
what about G for this is what I'm trying
to say yeah what what is he playing
after geforce g for my g4
hmm I'm not sure f4 maybe you can't play
that [ __ ] for takes takes Queen takes it
takes d5 threatening the Queen and
intending to go deform ok maybe this was
strong at forward I'm not sure this just
leads to the standard been only position
where I have fun the privilege of having
the early night f2n yeah yeah is this a
threat and Jack think I can just take it
if he goes if he goes beehive maybe I
could have played f4 but did you want to
spend yet again lots of time in the
early stages of the game yeah okay I'll
push this now the question is where to
put your pieces now small T to the
possible this Bishop f2 and allow us on
b5 so i go here covering the center it
is not attacked but i need to regroup
one way is probably Queen to f3 rookie a
to e one setting up the position for
later break through the d5 how yeah this
this really over now often happens like
Gong strikes because he someplace has
ran out of nala moves
and tries to unbalance okay anyway I can
take with the yeah with boats pieces 9
p-5 p maybe have c4 intending Bishop c4
94 hmm guy this looks a bit bit
confusing so maybe maybe go here yes
typical kind of position where white is
probably if you would play a
correspondence Khemia why this probably
flat-out winning black never has enough
compensation but it's often enough to
confuse matters so you can win over 200
blitz games with it but it's of course
not sufficient yeah maybe maybe they're
weird moves no night h5 threatening
bishops III I mean maybe he has
something but yeah this is what i meant
with weird moods okay but wow what the
heck is this okay hi goo night efore and
he goes bishops III
what the heck is this yeah well I'm
winning material but I know what what to
make of this position I'm [ __ ] both
works but it's so very confusing of
course okay maybe hook aaj trying to
play as active as possible queen bee 70
Queen a form and I don't really see what
else is going to play we need for then
I'm threatening night d 60 90 67 yeah I
don't I didn't see that one ah What What
nonsense yeah yeah this is always
frustrating you went to the plundering
stuff when the pony basically is losing
out of the opening okay so what now yeah
it's still still okay probably for what
96 I can't even play Queen f7 maybe this
one it's also see file hanging
and Queen hd5 this is a problem our
queen a 85 yeah maybe this is so good
enough still I don't know
okay let's grab it just down just a very
M we had position able to grab here I
don't know he's got a very strong bishop
I think it's unlikely that that I'm
having having something here really no
it's a girl probably
I mean it's please playing this really
badly I mean it was it was very Jewish
now I don't know of course the thymus
with an issue they are blended a 5mm
time morning
check Stanley yeah I probably should
have sort of one this but I played
simply too quickly here this this the
Supreme move basically if I don't do
that am i winning hmm yeah probably i am
i can i can take and his it's quite yeah
of course I need to need to go here this
one and no yeah one way to go with H
form I'm not not sure if this is the
best one but I can do an ID for this
looks this looks simple and good he
cannot allow night at five so because I
will take both pawns right f5 King to
jeff.wu and we are both he needs to go
here and after this it should be winning
I'm intending this and grabbing it yeah
this this King e2 was so yeah it wasn't
exactly a pre move but I i put this on
so quickly absolutely ignoring what he
did untung after Queenie after king e to
its it's probably a draw yeah thanks for
watching